Y debido a que los escribí muy claramente.
Podría entonces...
--finalmente descubrí--
ponerlos en algoritmos.
Y esos algoritmos serían incorporados en las computadoras,
y las computadoras tomarían decisiones conmigo;
y así en paralelo, tomaríamos estas decisiones.
Y podría ver cómo esas decisiones se comparan con mis propias decisiones,
y podría ver que esas decisiones son mucho mejores.
Y eso es porque la computadora podría tomar decisiones mucho más rápido.
Podría procesar mucha más información
y tomar decisiones mucho menos,
menos emocionales.
Así que mejoró radicalmente mi toma de decisiones.
Ocho años después empecé Bridgewater.
Tuve mi mayor fracaso,
mi mayor error.
Fue a finales de 1970,
tenía 34 años,
y había calculado que los bancos estadounidenses
habían prestado mucho más dinero a países emergentes
y esos países no serían capaces de devolvérselos
y que tendríamos la mayor crisis de deuda
desde la Gran Depresión.
Y, con ello, una crisis económica
y un gran mercado con acciones bajas.
Fue un raro punto de vista en ese momento.
La gente pensó que era un punto de vista alocado.
Pero en agosto de 1982,
México incumplió su deuda,
y muchos otros países lo siguieron.
Y así tuvimos la mayor crisis de deuda desde la Gran Depresión.
Y como yo había anticipado eso,
me solicitaron que testificara ante el Congreso y la revista de Wall Street
qué es lo que pasaba en ese momento.
Para que vean de lo que hablo, tengo aquí un video
y me verán allí.
(Video) Sr. Presidente, Sr. Mitchell,
es un gran placer y un honor estar ante Uds.
para analizar qué va mal en nuestra economía.
La economía ahora es plan...
se balancea al borde del fracaso.
Martin Zweig: Fue hace poco citado en un artículo.
Dijo: "Puedo decir esto con absoluta certeza
porque así funciona el mercado".
Ray Dalio: Puedo decir con absoluta certeza
que si miran la base de liquidez
en las corporaciones y el mundo en su conjunto,
verán un nivel tan reducido de liquidez
que no podrían volver a una era de "estanflación".
Miro eso ahora, y pienso: "¡Pero qué estúpido arrogante!"
(Risas)
Era arrogante y estaba muy equivocado.
Es decir, mientras la crisis de la deuda ocurría,
la bolsa de valores y la economía subieron en lugar de bajar,
y perdí tanto dinero mío y de mis clientes
que tuve que dar de baja mis operaciones,
tuve que dejar ir a casi todos.
Y eran como una familia extendida,
estaba con el corazón partido.
Y había perdido mucho dinero.
y tenía que pedir prestado USD 4000 de mi papá
para ayudar con las facturas familiares.
Fue una de las experiencias más dolorosas de mi vida...
pero resultó ser una de las más grandes experiencias de mi vida
porque cambió la manera en la que tomo decisiones.
En lugar de pensar "tengo razón",
empecé a preguntarme:
"¿Cómo sé que tengo razón?"
Conseguí la humildad que necesitaba
para equilibrarla con mi audacia.
Quería llegar a las personas más capaces que estuviesen en desacuerdo conmigo
para intentar entender sus perspectivas
o dejar que ellos probaran mi perspectiva.
Quería hacer una idea meritocrática.
En otras palabras,
no una autocracia en donde yo lideraría y otros me seguirían
y no una democracia donde los puntos de vista de todos son evaluados,
quería tener una idea meritocrática en donde las mejores ideas saldrían ganando.
Y para hacer esto
me di cuenta de que necesitaríamos una veracidad radical
y una transparencia radical.
Lo que quiero decir con estos términos
es que la gente necesita decir lo que en realidad piensa
y ver todo.
Y, literalmente, grabamos casi todas nuestras conversaciones
y dejamos a todos ver todo.
porque si no hacíamos eso,
no podíamos tener una verdadera idea meritocrática.
Para llegar a esto,
dejamos a las personas decir y opinar lo que quieren.
Para darles un ejemplo,
este es un email de Jim Haskel,
alguien que trabaja para mí,
y esto se le permite a todos en mi empresa:
"Ray, te mereces una mala nota
por tu rendimiento hoy en la reunión...
no te preparaste para nada bien
porque no hay razón para que estuvieras así de desorganizado.
¿No es genial?
(Risas)
Es genial.
Lo es porque, antes que nada, necesitaba una opinión como esa.
La necesito.
Y es genial porque si no dejo a Jim, y a otros como Jim,
expresar sus puntos de vista,
nuestra relación no sería la misma.
Y si no dejo que todos los demás lo vean,
no tendríamos una idea de meritocracia.
Así que durante los últimos 25 años así fue como operamos.
Trabajamos con esta transparencia radical
y luego, recolectando estos principios
la mayoría sobre cometer errores,
y luego colocando esos principios en algoritmos.
Y luego esos algoritmos proveen...
nosotros estamos siguiendo los algoritmos
en paralelo con nuestras ideas.
Así fue como manejamos el negocio de inversiones
y así es como lidiamos con la gestión de las personas.
Para darles un pantallazo sobre como se ve esto,
me gustaría llevarlos a una reunión
y presentarles una herramienta nuestra llamada "colector de puntos"
que nos ayuda con esto.
Una semana tras las elecciones de EE.UU.,
nuestro equipo de investigación se reunió
para hablar sobre la presidencia de Trump y la economía estadounidense.
Naturalmente, la gente tenía diferentes opiniones al respecto
y sobre cómo abordaríamos la discusión.
El "colector de puntos" recolectó estos puntos de vista.
Tiene una lista de varias decenas de atributos
así que cada vez que alguien piensa algo sobre las ideas de otra persona,
es fácil para ellos transmitir su evaluación
simplemente seleccionan el atributo y lo califican del 1 al 10.
Por ejemplo, cuando comenzó la reunión
una investigadora llamada Jen me calificó con un 3
-- en otras palabras, mal --
(Risas)
por no mostrar un buen equilibrio de mente abierta y asertividad.
A medida que transcurrió la reunión,
las evaluaciones de Jen sobre las personas ocurrieron de esta manera.
Otros allí, tuvieron diferentes opiniones.
Es normal.
Diferentes personas siempre van a tener diferentes opiniones.
¿Y quién sabe quién tiene razón?
Veamos lo que la gente pensaba acerca de cómo estaba.
Algunas personas pensaron que lo hice bien,
otros no.
Con todas estas opiniones,
podemos explorar el pensamiento que hay detrás de los números.
Aquí está lo que dieron Jen y Larry.
Tengan en cuenta que todos expresan sus pensamientos
incluyendo su pensamiento crítico,
independientemente de su posición en la compañía.
Jen, que tiene 24 años y acaba de salir de la universidad,
puede decirme, al CEO, que tengo un enfoque terrible.
Esta herramienta le ayuda a las personas a expresar sus opiniones
y luego separarlas de sus opiniones
para ver las cosas de un nivel más alto.
Cuando Jen y otros cambian sus atención de introducir sus propias opiniones
a ver toda la pantalla,
sus perspectivas cambian.
Ven sus propias opiniones como solo una de muchas
y naturalmente, empiezan a preguntarse:
"¿Cómo sé si mi opinión es acertada?"
Ese cambio en la perspectiva es como pasar de mirar en una dimensión
a mirar en múltiples dimensiones.
Y cambia la conversación desde argumentar nuestras opiniones
a encontrar criterios objetivos para determinar qué opiniones son las mejores.
Detrás del "recolector de puntos" hay una computadora que observa.
Observa todo lo que estas personas piensan
y relaciona esto con cómo lo piensan.
Y ofrece consejos a cada uno basado en ello.
Luego, dibuja los datos de todas las reuniones
para crear una imagen de puntos de cómo son las personas
y cómo piensan.
Y hace esto guiado por algoritmos.
Saber cómo son las personas les ayuda a coincidir mejor con sus trabajos.
Por ejemplo, un pensador creativo que es irresponsable
puede ser puesto con alguien responsable pero no creativo.
Saber cómo son las personas también nos permite decidir
qué responsabilidades darles
y medir nuestras decisiones basándonos en el mérito de las personas.
Lo llamamos credibilidad.
Aquí hay un ejemplo de un voto que tomamos
donde la mayoría de la gente se sentía de una manera...
pero si medimos las opiniones basadas en los méritos
la respuesta es muy diferente.
Este proceso nos permite tomar decisiones no basadas en la democracia
ni basadas en la autocracia,
sino en algoritmos que consideran la credibilidad de las personas.
Sí, en serio hacemos esto.
(Risas)
Lo hacemos porque elimina
lo que creo es una de las mayores tragedias de la humanidad,
y eso es gente arrogante
e ingenua que sostienen opiniones equivocadas,
y actuar sobre ellas,
y no poniéndolos sobre la mesa y poniéndolos a prueba.
Y eso es una tragedia.
Y lo hacemos porque nos eleva en nuestras propias opiniones.
Para que podamos ver las cosas a través de los ojos de todos,
para ver las cosas colectivamente.
La toma de decisiones colectiva es mejor que la toma de decisiones individual
si se hace bien.
Ha sido el ingrediente secreto de nuestro éxito.
Así hicimos más dinero para los clientes
que cualquier otro fondo de cobertura existente
ganando dinero 23 años de los últimos 26 años.
Entonces, ¿cuál es el problema con ser radicalmente honestos
y radicalmente transparentes entre sí?
La gente dice que es emocionalmente difícil.
Los críticos dicen que es la fórmula para un ambiente de trabajo bestial.
Los neurocientíficos dicen que así está cableado el cerebro.
A una parte del cerebro le gustaría saber nuestros errores
y le gustaría ver nuestras debilidades para así mejorar.
Me dijeron que ese es el córtex prefrontal.
Y también hay una parte del cerebro que ve todo esto como un ataque.
Me dijeron que esa es la amígdala.
En otras palabras, hay dos "yo" dentro de cada uno:
hay un "yo" emocional
y hay un "yo" intelectual
y a veces están en desacuerdo,
y a veces están en contra.
Sabemos por experiencia que podemos ganar esta batalla.
La ganamos como grupo.
Típicamente lleva unos 18 meses
ver que la mayoría de la gente prefiere operar de esta manera,
con una transparencia radical
que operar en un ambiente más opaco.
No hay política, no existe la brutalidad de...
me entienden, todo lo típico entre bastidores,
hay una idea meritocrática donde las personas tienen voz.
Y eso ha sido genial.
Nos dio un trabajo más efectivo,
y también nos dio relaciones más efectivas.
Pero no es para todos.
Encontramos que cerca del 25 o 30 % de la población
simplemente no puede hacerlo.
Y, por cierto,
cuando digo transparencia radical,
no estoy hablando de la transparencia sobre todo.
Sino de no tener que decirle a alguien que cada vez está más calvo
o que su bebé es feo.
Solo estoy hablando de...
(Risas)
hablando de las cosas importantes.
Así que...
(Risas)
Así que cuando dejen la sala,
me gustaría que se observen conversando con otros.
Imaginen si supieran lo que en realidad estuvieron pensando,
e imaginen si supieran cómo son ellos en realidad...
e imaginen si ellos supieran lo que Uds. pensaron
y cómo son en realidad.
Seguramente, se les aclararán mucho las cosas
y hagan sus operaciones juntos más efectivas.
Yo creo que mejorará su relación.
Ahora imagínense que tienen algoritmos
que les ayudan a unir esa información,
incluso les ayudan a tomar decisiones de una manera meritocrática.
Este tipo de transparencia radical se acerca a Uds.
y afectará sus vidas.
Y en mi opinión,
va a ser maravilloso.
Así que espero que sea tan maravilloso para Uds.
como lo es para mí.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)